s'agissant des questions posées par
l'intervenant a
confirmé que nous travaillons
activement au sujet de l'évaluation de
la fraude
nous comme je m'y étais engagé nous
avons pour cela à la fois engagé un
travail lourd de
benchmarking ou plutôt pardon de pargo
nage avec à la fois nos collègues des
autres branches et des autres opérateurs
comparable sécurité sociale pour
l'emploi des et fip est également à
l'engrenage avec nos collègues d'autres
pays étrangers d'autres systèmes
d'assurance-maladie ou essayer de
partager les méthodes délai pour avancer
sur cette évaluation la fraude je
partage avec vous non pas pour
minorer
les mérites de nos collègues mais
classions semaine d'évaluation de la
fraude à l'assurance maladie et un objet
particulièrement complexe compte tenu de
la diversité de ses champs
d'intervention aux prestations en nature
prestations en espèces fraudes
potentielles d assurer des
professionnels de santé fraude à
l'hôpital ou dans ville
et donc nous sommes face à un champ qui
en réalité pose pour chaque profession
presque et pour chaque prestation des
problématiques différentes pour autant
nous sommes très mobilisés sur ce sujet
notre objectif et deux d'avancé en deux
temps d'ici la fin d'année 2021
partagé avec le parlement évidemment le
nos tutelles des premières évaluations
de la fraude sur un certain nombre de
champs de l'offre de soins et des
chambres différentes prestations que
nous gérons et donc nous travaillons ce
sens avec notamment la direction de la
sécurité sociale pour partager des
premières évaluations et l'objectif
d'avoir un panorama plus complet
j'espère complet dans tous les cas plus
complet que ce que nous ferons d'ici la
fin d'année 2021 d'ici là le milieu
d'année 2022 et donc pour essayer de
mettre sur un certain nombre de sur la
plupart des champs couverts par
l'assurance maladie
des évaluations chiffrées de l'ampleur
de la fraude mais l'exercice est en
réalité techniquement compliqué nous
conduit à utiliser des méthodes
statistiques assez fine vous avez parlé
d'échantillonnage nous travaillons sur
les méthodes de également de par
stratification met donc nous nous sommes
mobilisés sur ce sujet donc de rendez
vous avant la fin d'année 2021 et un
autre d'ici le milieu de l'année 2022
[Musique]